spectacle gadoue et émotion c'est
l'occasion de découvrir des disciplines
sportives comme la randonnée en quad ou
des engins tout terrain qui devrait se
trouver dans un jardin le tracteur
tondeuse
les passionnés récupère les engins à la
casse pour les personnaliser et assurer
le spectacle
ça me surtout avec on n'est pas là pour
faire des courses à avoir des accidents
on est là pour mettre de l'animation on
a un système avec de l'huile de
paraffine
on en voit dans le pot d'échappement
quand il est bien chaud et ce qui fait
qu'on a une fumée importante qui donne
l'impression d'avoir un moteur gaiement
mais en fin de compte et les pandores le
moteur c'est pour faire du spectacle il
y en a qui vont jusqu'à 40 50 à l'heure
mais bon sur du sur du plat mais en
compétition la moyenne vous savez quand
on a fait 20 25 km heure ce qui va bien
c'est déjà très bien
les comment la pelouse après my happy
d'herbe il ya pas besoin de coupe mais y
a plus d'herbe
alors s'il ya des personnes intéressés
pour faire leur pelouse qu'on arrive on
tourne deux heures et c'est bon on n'est
plus rien autre engin singulier letren
qu une voiture de récupération coupé en
deux de sept chevaux maximum à l'arrière
la structure repose sur deux roulettes
est interdit de toucher aux pièces
d'origine sauf la carrosserie elle peut
être modifiée de façon humoristique
le plaisir c'est parce que c'est un
sport qui est à la portée de tout le
monde c'est très convivial tout le monde
se
ce sens à vis d'eux
ces idées
et donne un coup de main différents ou
des chirons pilotes
il n'y a pas de course il a pas d'argent
qui est en jeu et c'est un gosse est un
loisir
ces véhicules ne sont pas homologuée sur
route alors autant en profiter dans un
champ en toute sécurité